hello welcome to three scary games
mark is not here but don't you worry
today we have a great spooky video
recorded in front of a live stream
audience
enjoy the spooks but please beware
something is out there keep your eyes
peeled
like this
[Music]
[Applause]
i think this one is based off the exact
same uh engine and model as like buff
among us
buff imposter or whatever it was i think
there's literally no difference here but
i won't try it anyway
all right let's see what's up oh my god
the mouse sensitivity
press f flashlight right
all right uh-oh
maze always changes every time
right i remember
[Music]
oh
uh
hi
needs something
no you need something from me i don't
even know what you could provide
why are you staring at me
freaking what if you try to fight him
you will lose
what are you stupid or what
hey come on now i'm just trying to look
at your pretty face what are you are you
stupid why are you staring at me because
i feel like it what's up with you
what do you want you're the one who
joined me here what's your problem to
keep looking at me like that i'm i'm not
gonna look away you know what i had a
staring contest with ethan for like
eight minutes stop staring at me hey try
try me try me you look away why don't
you look away don't listen to him who uh
dude
what why does it have to be me why don't
you go somewhere else i may do a trick
i'm looking forward to tear him apart
who
who
stop staring at me this is so weird your
stare is creepy your face is creepy do i
have something between my teeth oddly
enough you don't have teeth so that's
not exactly a concern of mine you look
pretty oh thank you that's awfully sweet
you don't who do you think you are
looking at what are you looking at what
what do you what do you look at
what were you looking at staring at me i
might
i might just
what are you looking at you have
beautiful laws so do alive not you you
owe me no
if i could i would
if i could i really really would you
know this is what i love in games things
that are like not pertinent to thing but
just like continuous more and more the
more you dig i know it's like
thank you
i know it's like hard to do stuff i
think this is the wrong way
probably
thanks
hi
are you just gonna keep doing that
you could keep doing that i wouldn't go
in there
researchers once turned a live cat into
a telephone why
why do you know that why would that be a
thing i wouldn't go in there
i guess i won't either
did you hear that no was it your
blabbering creepy room
i would choose another door
i'm so tired of dying
okay man
hi
you found me
congratulations
oh my god
[Applause]
me something no
i'm good man i'm good nothing in here
yeah i know
i know man what this game is will you go
in the wrong direction how about you
point me in the right direction
you would be
you would be man
wrong way says you
i love this like so much work put into
such a simple concept
you know what i mean
i would choose another door yeah well
you're a creepy monkey so uh i can't
exactly choose another you
yes
love it i'm the best
i'm the hi
gosh
you scared me sure yeah
man
hi
i made us t it's just such a silly
concept of like this but it's so well
done
you will always be running
okay
thanks thank you didn't think you would
show up here
i didn't think that you'd ever leave me
alone for a moment
and yet here you did
just like everything constantly changes
like perpetually changing is such a fun
concept
you get away from me what are you doing
and just like things like this changing
in the darkness it's so
the details you know the details
says you
scared potter and the monkey look man
i'm trying i'm trying
i wish i could
hey look at that
i don't know if those arrows on the
ground actually help
but not fast enough
well you're stupid but not stupid enough
strange
why am i here i don't know why am i here
[Music]
i'm back yep
good man good
good stuff strange
why am i here i don't know
i don't know man
i can't kill him
freak you man he's so dark
yeah almost like darkipliers here huh
i made us tea
i love this monkey i love this but it's
gonna get old real fast i can already
tell hi
that is weird isn't it if you
want to live
run now
okay
all right man i'm so tired of dying
okay all right we
oh god
no no watch this supreme skill
okay i made it
i am the best
confess my weakness
oh hi
no i did not hear that am i free what
are you looking for a burger i'm looking
for a burger
a bregoire
you ever seen a burger
i don't remember meeting you
researchers once turned a live cat into
a telephone great story man
please
please pretty please please what please
me and go away would love that would
love that actually are you looking for
something i told you a bergwar
you are all you're all alone god i wish
i end up here i don't know a gun
i'll use you i have a gun
on you
could you
delete my homework folder for me
please is that where you keep your porn
help me
some guy shot me
oh never mind it just you again
killing me will get rid of me uh i'm
seeing that but you know it feels better
oh
monkey death
oh my god that is so funny
yep
still here
still dead
my god
what a game
some guy shot me
[Applause]
take some of this
[Laughter]
i'm gonna i'm gonna leave that one there
because i don't want it to overstay its
welcome i have defeated buff doge
at his own game wasn't buff enough to
stop my bullets god that was so fun
i didn't even know i would fall in love
with that monkey character but wow i
thought this was just going to be a
reskin of the uh the buff among us
imposter but it had that monkey and i
never thought that that monkey would add
depth to the game
god what a fun game
really love that truly very very good
very good anyway
moving on
i've been told with 100 certainty that
there are no snakes in this game there
are absolutely zero snakes
choo choo charles oh hell yeah that
looks awesome i will absolutely wish
list that that looks dope as hell look
at that oh them that that bodes well for
this one all right but this is no snake
hotel
let's find out how true that
with a is
no snake guarantee here at the no snake
hotel we pride ourselves in our
incomprehensible lack of snakes
at other hotels you run the constant
risk of finding a snake in your
bedsheets a snake in your toilet or even
waking up to a snake sliding down your
throat it happens more than you'd think
call the front desk for questions and
enjoy your stay at the no snake
hotel okay
[Music]
you know if i didn't know any better
i might assume that there might be some
snakes in this but there seems to be
such good guarantees i just arrived at
the hotel good golly bart this place is
immaculate you know how much i hate
snakes so i went out of my way to stay
at the no snake hotel they've really
done it bart there are absolutely no
snakes in this hotel
[Music]
[Laughter]
anyway
find room 100 all right i can do that
123. one two three okay
got it one
one two two okay one two two okay
one two one
one two oh
uh-huh got it one one hey where one one
nine
one one nine i
thought i saw something
i'm living the dream i didn't think it
was possible but i sure am happy it is
the no snake hotel really lives up to
its name ever since i was a little girl
and got abducted by an army of rabid
snakes while on vacation i haven't left
my house after 50 years in solitude i
finally have a safe place where i can
vacation thanks no snake hotel
well i mean this seems great
this seems dope as hell
wow
one
115
four oh look at the chairs one one three
one one two
this could be 100
maybe not
oh everywhere except here yeah no
kidding
i feel safer than ever here one time at
some other hotel i walk
[Music]
i walked into my room and when i turned
around to shut the door there was a
snake as long as my arm dangling from
the coat hook but here at no snake hotel
i don't need to worry about that creepy
slithering creature oh what creepy
slithering creatures might be standing
directly behind me and directly behind
you because you're not at no snake hotel
unlike me
okay
one one one
one
oh
109 108
this must be uh
[Music]
oh yeah
well that seems fine i'm gonna assume
that's
ah
it's a snake oh damn it
they promised
dude i don't like the darkness
i choose oh i should have chose the
darkness okay
oh hey hey
uh
uh
[Music]
was there a way to run away from me did
i mess that up
did i miss it i gotta go back guys i got
i gotta go back let me out let me out
let me out there's gotta be another way
that shadow area that seemed like the
dark path you know what i mean wink wink
wink it seemed like there was something
dark going on there and uh you know if
if i'm not mistaken something something
dark
down there might be waiting for me you
know something dark wink wink wink might
be waiting for markiplier you know a
dark zone at the end of the hallway
might be waiting for uh
this guy i i kind of like whenever i see
a dark area i run straight for it i run
straight for it oh i can't run straight
forward
i'm running away from it somehow i don't
know how
hey
i was in the levator there's no way that
the dark path would have betrayed me
there must have been something wrong
with the game i better try it again
whenever i see a dark path i jump right
into it and there's no way that it could
lie to me and i won't let it lie to me
because i will not be lied to there is
something dark down there and i'm gonna
find it the darkness has something for
markiplier it's like an empire made
darkness
you know what i mean
i think you know what i mean i'm gonna
go down into whatever that darkness is
one could say i'm gonna go down on that
darkness i'm gonna go down on the dark
that's what i'm gonna do that's what i'm
gonna do
bling
oh yeah i'm turning and i'm running
out of order oh no
all right okay
betrayed betrayed by the darkness i
would say i like that a lot that was
very fun
short but fun
moving on
this is amanda the adventurer um
i'm thinking it must be something based
off of like dora the explorer
but uh
not 100 sure episode one
okay
oh this looks lovely i can't i'm amanda
and i'm wooly
and i love apples do you like apples
whoa uh no i'm allergic to apples
that's okay you should never be afraid
to try something new but we don't even
know where the store is
do you know where the store is
okay
is this the store are you the store
do you know where the store is
do you know where this door is
here
yeah that's right let's go
we're at the store it sure looks crowded
and look there are apples can you see
apple
no
nope
say apple
apple
okay
um
moderately concerning about that uh is
there something else going on here that
i need to be worried about i feel like i
should be able to just turn all this off
and back away but uh
not seeing that as an option so i'm
guessing i just move forward okay
episode two
okay
oh
you
okay we don't have much time whatever
you do
hi everyone i'm amanda and i'm willie
today we're going to get meat for
grandma
but is it grandma a vegetarian can you
tell us where the butcher is
the butcher the the butcher the butcher
can you tell us where the butter is
here
the butter
um
you know i would really love but i have
a bad feeling you're going to uh butcher
your sheep friend here and that's not
going to go well
uh for uh the sheep friend and then me i
might be next so
there it is let's go
i love me man
can you tell the meat man what we need
no apple
can you tell me what we need
no
no
tell them what we need
oh boy
mark
m a
r
it's just filling it in for me guys i
don't
okay
so
[Applause]
[Music]
didn't like the way you were looking at
that sheep i'm thinking that my theory
my uh my lore might be correct here guys
i might uh i might have nailed the lore
of this can you tell me what episode we
should do next
can you tell me where episode three is
can you tell me where else
that's right it's here
all right
oh god
it's dark out let's go home
great
what is this
what's this uh
unidentifiable pile of nothing what's uh
what's this
playground
huh
playground
went to the house
what
point to the house is how you said oh i
don't know if i want to uh i'd rather
not actually
oh
oh is this my house oh please no i don't
like that
oh
oh
no
oh
that ain't good
[Music]
whoa yeah
i wanna try that again what happens if
you do what amanda says the whole time
i'm kind of curious
these are really cool i like this
concept it's super fun i like this very
simple
um not complicated but it really like
gives a good feel to it right hi i'm
amanda hi i'm bullying wow i love apple
do you like apple
yes
yes i'm allergic to apples
that's okay you should never be afraid
to try something new but we don't even
know where the store is
do you know where the store is yeah
yeah oh i see it still does it anyway
can you see apple
apple good job now we can make apple pie
huh yeah there's got to be like a secret
to this there's got to be a secret
because like some of you pointed out
like at the end there were five letters
it could have been apple it could have
been
apple us where the butcher is
there it is let's go
hello
hi me man
hey man can you tell the meat man what
we need
can you tell the meat man what we need
i don't think it works
tell them what we need
i'm trying
hmm it's not in space with mark blair
there's no secrets you might be right
about that but there could be just like
no one's found the jump in again secret
and in space with markiplier some
secrets are just so well hidden you'd
never even know
what is this what is this
what is this
oh
oh okay six letters
a-m-a-n-d-a
amanda amanda
oh
six six amanda
oh
maybe maybe not i have no idea
butcher
butcher
myrrh
oh
oh
was i supposed to type that in
fascinating it's dark out
let's go home
knock on the door
[Music]
interesting app say hello wait didn't
that say
hello
hmm
i should have done apple there's got to
be more right there's got to be more
okay what if i actually put in woolly
for that secret one because i think
there must have been something about
that it won't it like gave me the answer
at the end but i could have typed that
in before right gotta be something can
you say apple
yep uh
i feel like there's got to be a secret
thing you can put in for each of these
right for each spot there has to be
something you can type in that is a
secret because there's three letters on
the first one there's five letters on
the next one
here there's four letters the secret
video has six letters it wants you to
say wooly
like i don't know if it gives you that
secret take just because you're playing
it again or because you type in lamb
because there's the secret tape
okay so if you type in wooly it just
goes there right away
why
oh that's a good idea
that's a good idea
nah that doesn't do anything either oh i
know i tr i did type in amanda before
that did work let me try this one more
time okay so what i'm gonna do is in
this entry i'm gonna type in girl let's
see what that does can you tell the meat
man what we need
nah
tell them what we need
i don't know if that would do anything
that's right nah
yeah and that doesn't give you okay
there's gotta be there's got to be
something else because we didn't get the
secret that was caused by saying lamb
so there's another element here
that has to be a part of this but i i
highly doubt that there would be
anything in this game that you would not
be able to get from playing the game in
terms of clues right
nonsense
this is nonsense let me look up
something
when in doubt
cheat i'm so guessing that there's more
stuff to this there's gotta be there's
gotta be
maybe there's not and maybe there's
nothing more maybe that extra tape is
the only thing i'm gonna guess that's it
all right whatever that was very good i
liked that a lot it was creepy
interesting had new thing but yeah i i
think it should have totally way way way
more secrets in there should definitely
have way more secrets if there are i may
revisit it but i'll i'm also might wait
until um until there's some more
substance there
thank you for watching
this three scary games video
spooky right i hope you enjoyed it
mark is gone
see you next time
bye bye
[Music]
you